el profesor sin importar la mirada o la
opinión que uno tenga sobre este tema
Cuál es el valor histórico que tiene
esta fecha el 12 de octubre para la
humanidad entera
Buenas noches Santiago y muchas gracias
por la invitación y para responder con
tu pregunta y es indudable el valor que
tiene el 12 de octubre a pesar de las
diferencias de las posturas encontradas
que puedan haber no solamente es que la
historia sino en general de las ciencias
sociales y por parte de la de la
sociedad en general el 12 de octubre
representa lo que fue
un cambio en la época bueno en la en la
historia humana el descubrimiento de un
gran continente que sí que el efecto
existía pero se descubre para la
sociedad occidente occidental la
sociedad europea la sociedad asiática
entre otras y representa ese cambio de
la Edad Media a la modernidad una época
en la cual
seres humanos la sociedad tiene su
conjunto se vio en la necesidad de
afrontar este nuevo descubrimiento
improvisando y a la vez perfeccionando
por ejemplo técnicas de navegación todo
lo que fue la importancia de llegada de
nuevos alimentos a Europa y su
distribución por el viejo mundo por Asia
por África y Asimismo el intercambio
comercial que empieza a existir a raíz
entonces de octubre profesor Sánchez con
la perspectiva que hay actual de la
sociedad del tema de derechos humanos de
la historia de los países lo que
significa el 12 de octubre como la fecha
del descubrimiento
del continente para otros pues significa
el inicio de un genocidio o la
imposición de una religión o de un
modelo social o de un idioma procedente
de Europa ha cambiado la forma de
enseñarle a los estudiantes en la
actualidad este hecho histórico que es
importante según usted lo explicaba en
la pregunta anterior
bueno y te la enseñanza Universitaria en
efecto
se ha dado una transformación en la
enseñanza de este acontecimiento
histórico
cada vez son más comunes la
reivindicaciones de los pueblos
originarios y la importancia que tienen
estos desde la historiografía desde las
ciencias sociales los estudiantes ya no
solamente llegan y se les enseña la
visión eurocéntrica sino también la
misma visión
autóctona la
importancia pero también las
consecuencias tanto positivas como
negativos que tiene el proceso del
descubrimiento y posteriormente de la
conquista
lastimosamente
dentro de las aulas de la enseñanza
secundaria de la enseñanza primaria y la
transformación no ha sido como uno
quisiera porque se siguen replicando
muchas veces
recursos tradicionales y no se ha puesto
a debatir o analizar realmente las
consecuencias que tiene para esto Pero
indudablemente ha habido una
transformación en estos años